[Musique]
il y a trois mille ans sur le continent européen
les premiers peuples se forment mais à ceux
fois la vie humaine n'a pas beaucoup de valeur
[Musique]
les hommes s'entre-tuent pour
conquête de territoires et qui ne meurt pas
au combat, il est asservi par
gagnants les millénaires passent les
Continent européen
connaît la domination de la culture grecque
Occupation romaine et germanique mais en
1000 après christ
la vie humaine vaut encore très peu
[Musique]
salués comme des héros guerriers de la colère
bouchers authentiques et continuer la
la chasse aux esclaves à travers la mer
convertir à leur dieu ceux qui
ils ne savent pas que Dieu est un concept
répandu en Europe par quelques prêtres
venant du Moyen-Orient
ces hommes visionnaires prêchent une
dimension divine
au-delà du monde réel, ils prétendent que
il n'y a qu'un seul dieu créateur du ciel e
de la terre et de l'homme et que ce dieu
il a envoyé ou son fils jésus sur terre
pardonner les péchés des êtres
humains
cependant les désaccords sur ce même dieu
provoquer des conflits sanglants
conflits religieux ou frontaliers
continuer jusqu'au XXe siècle avec
les guerres mondiales qui ravagent
continent européen causant des millions de
morte
[Musique]
enfin une belle journée de l'année 1945
après avoir versé tant de sang et tant
les larmes les maîtres du monde cessent
l'hostilité et signer la paix
[Musique]
les marchandises sont ensuite échangées
plutôt que de voler le commerce
prospère et la vie devient délicate
équilibre pour ne plus gérer avec
des armes mais avec la négociation elles émergent
puis les deux puissances victorieuses
États de la dernière guerre mondiale
uni et l'union soviétique
les états-unis soutiennent
capitalisme et lutte pour le contrôle
monde global soumis au leur
ordres
puisque les guerres mondiales n'ont pas eu lieu
menées sur leur continent
les états-unis peuvent produire et
vendre une énorme quantité d'armes sans
être dérangé en devenant tellement
riches pour imposer le dollar américain
comme monnaie internationale à la place
De leur
l'Union soviétique, d'autre part, soutient la
communisme et dictature
son territoire est le plus vaste de
planète et à la fin des guerres
La Coupe du monde comprend également des pays
europe de l'est europe
elle est pour sa part au centre des intérêts
des états-unis et de l'union
soviétique
se retrouver face à face à ce sujet
le continent est épuisé par les guerres
Coupe du monde
ce n'est pas difficile pour ces deux puissances
le diviser pour former deux blocs le
bloc bleu de l'idéologie capitaliste
qui regroupe les pays d'Europe
occidentale sous l'influence
les états-unis et le bloc rouge
de l'idéologie communiste qui regroupe
pays d'europe de l'est ci-dessous
l'influence de l'Union soviétique et de la
guerre froide entre les deux blocs ai
antipodes sur la façon de penser
dans le bloc rouge la propriété et du
déclarer que la liberté de voyager est limitée
le commerce est contrôlé et la
la compétition est interdite dans le bloc bleu à
contraire à la propriété et au privé
la liberté de mouvement est totale et la
le commerce et la concurrence sont libres
au fil des ans un énorme
la richesse des états-unis me favorise
citoyens du bloc bleu exhibant
leur satisfaction
cela provoque l'envie silencieuse des dieux
citoyens du bloc rouge dont le régime
n'admet pas la contradiction
cependant un pays rouge la pologne utilise
un jour se rebeller en revendiquant
aspirations légitimes de l'homme là-bas
la pologne veut sortir du système
communiste pour embrasser le capitalisme
que s'il n'offre pas toujours le confort
il semble au moins offrir la liberté
[Musique]
pensant qu'aucun pays n'oserait
interviennent et dans leurs affaires intérieures
car ce serait trop dangereux pour
toute personne se mêlant des affaires
du bloc rouge redouté dans le monde
les dirigeants de l'union soviétique décident de
occuper ce pays militairement
rebelle
[Musique]
cependant cette menace d'invasion de
un pays qui se proclame à eux
frère suscite l'indignation des dirigeants
du bloc bleu se rassemblent alors
d'urgence d'élaborer un plan contre
cette agression dès que possible et sans
provoquer des guerres doit déchirer
la pologne au bloc communiste faisant en
pour que les capirossi sous le regard
du monde entier ne peut intervenir
le faire affaiblirait
considérablement l'adversaire rouge
cherche un plan diaboliquement
intelligent après avoir longtemps réfléchi
immergé au plus profond d'eux
les pensées
les dirigeants du bloc bleu se retrouvent
forcément devant dieu dieu
les leaders bleus sont des gens
les pragmatiques doutent de l'existence de
Dieu
hors intervention divine sur laquelle
vous ne pouvez pas compter alors pensez à la
peuple de dieu à l'église à ses fidèles
quand l'un d'eux a sa propre idée géniale
sainteté
[Musique]
et je sais que les Européens sont de la
bloc bleu à bloc rouge sont consacrés
le destin te suivra vers le même dieu
de l'église maintenant et si
sa sainteté le représentant de dieu
sur terre était un prêtre natif du
Pologne
ce pays sur le point d'être
attaqué et si son
la sainteté en tant qu'homme qu'il ressentait
devoir de défendre sa patrie
qui oserait le frapper
parmi les soldats rouges qui sont des gens du
gens et qui l'aiment comme un père
cela empêcherait probablement
l'invasion quelques jours après
Rencontre
soudain sa sainteté meurt
fortement poussé par les leaders bleus l'église
puis il lit beaucoup comme sa sainteté
Prêtre polonais cet homme ne perd pas de temps
le jour même de sa consécration
envoyer un message à toutes les nations
du monde déclare que si son pays
sera attaqué atteindra personnellement
la frontière et flanqué de dieu le père
maudira pour l'éternité
quiconque a osé frapper la tête du
église
le message passe partout
fait rapidement un énorme bruit
les nations et les églises immédiatement
du monde font savoir que celui-ci est
sainteté et d'être protégé comme
représentant d'un dieu même s'il n'est pas
en eux
en même temps les états-unis et moi
les pays du bloc bleu déclarent que si
le chef de l'église devait être dans
le danger interviendrait militairement
aussi l'impact sur la population de
le bloc rouge est considérable
l'idée que sa sainteté est tuée par
leurs propres militaires agitent les leurs
mensonge l'anathème lancé par le saint homme
rappelez-vous que si la vie est courte l'âme
éternel et personne ne veut se salir là-bas
propre toujours frapper la tête
de l'église pour les capirossi là
la situation est délicate
s'ils veulent éviter un conflit avec le
reste du monde ils n'en ont plus qu'un
la solution
ce grand prêtre doit mourir
[Musique]
si son ancienne sainteté est décédée
tout à coup et c'était définitivement
même le courant assassiné ou mourir
tout à coup le monde pense à un
malédiction divine ou à une intrigue si le
le crime ne laisse aucune trace
personne n'aura à se plaindre
cette invasion coûte cher
ce qu'il en coûte et fermement le
l'histoire enseigne qu'il est plus sûr d'être
craint que d'être aimé
cependant l'empoisonnement et sa sainteté ne sont pas
possible
le siège de l'église situé dans le bloc
le bleu est impénétrable mais il est d'usage que le
chef de l'église sortir en public
pendant les fêtes religieuses entouré
par les nombreux fidèles qui ac la
main avec de grands cris de joie
c'est alors que sa sainteté sortira de son
imeuble
profitant de la confusion qui règne
bon moment pour le tuer caché entre les deux
la foule
le tueur peut s'échapper et si vous le faites
prendre doit apparaître comme le geste
isolé d'un imbécile qui comment ça se passe
tue souvent une personne connue pour
savourer la notoriété
[Musique]
le risque est pourtant grand
le complot doit rester secret e
doit se dépêcher
pour commettre ce meurtre ils viennent
puis choisissez des guerriers qui ne le font pas
Ils n'ont rien a perdre
ce sont des hommes durs qui obéissent et
sont muets
condamné à mort pour des crimes
ils seront pardonnés et bien récompensés si
ils réussiront cet exploit nécessaire
à l'équilibre du continent
ces guerriers partent donc entrent
se faufilant dans le bloc bleu qu'ils atteignent
l'église et au bon moment oui
s'infiltrer dans la foule des fidèles
l'un d'eux s'approche de sa sainteté e
parmi les cris, craignez de les présenter
tire froidement deux balles dans
coeur plein
mais évidemment dieu existe et de mais le
son prêtre bien frappé d'un côté à l'autre
sa sainteté survit à cette embuscade
et tandis que le monde crie d'horreur et de
miracle accusant l'union soviétique là-bas
Pologne
se réjouit bonne chance a empêché le
la mort de son prêtre et l'invasion
déclare donc l'indépendance immédiatement
aidé par une énorme somme d'argent
prêté au bloc bleu de
face à toute cette richesse
les populations du bloc rouge restent
étourdi
quand le bloc bleu promet grand
prêt à tous les pays rouges qui
ils veulent rejoindre la situation maintenant
chaque citoyen devient incontrôlable
le communiste veut embrasser le système
capitaliste c'est la fin de l'union
soviétique
sa nation est le chef de la russie
dissoudre le bloc rouge permettant
l'indépendance aux pays subjugués e
il bloque également sa propre production de
armes faisant allusion au bloc bleu
qui doit maintenant soutenir les pays qui
il a su attirer les dirigeants de leur côté
promesse bleue toutes sortes d'aide
ils sont satisfaits de ne pas avoir utilisé
armes et ces pays sont nouveaux
des clients désireux d'acheter tout ça
qui ne trouvent pas d'eux leur plan a
travaillé le bloc ouest ai
domination sur les armes mais contre qui
utiliser ces armes et maintenant que le
l'ennemi rouge est souriant et désarmé
en effet l'animosité entre les peuples
frères qui se connaissent depuis toujours est
disparition
puis comme dans une grande famille où
tous sont unis mais chacun et lui-même
Les Européens retroussent leurs manches e
la bonne volonté l'emporte
[Musique]
mais un nouvel obstacle sérieux se dresse sur le chemin
l'économie européenne
beaucoup de ses anciens états étaient des puissances
les championnats du monde progressent rapidement après
les ruines des dernières guerres et cela
inquiète les états-unis qu'après la
dissolution du bloc rouge sont
devenir les seuls maîtres de l'Europe
puisque leur plan n'admet pas
concurrents mais seulement des vassaux asservis
les États-Unis complotent pour s'affaiblir
les États européens qui ont besoin ici
les complices s'entendent alors en secret
avec l'Allemagne promettant le sien
suprématie tant désirée sur l'Europe
et pousser jusqu'à ce que la fusion soit réalisée
des pays européens dans une structure
supranational
l'Union européenne
l'idée est belle mais le piège est tendu par les dieux
pays de langue et de traditions
différents enchaînés pour une journée
à l'autre ils prennent des décisions difficiles
unitaire surtout lorsqu'il est à la tête de
cette union sont placés des dieux
Économistes européens diplômés aux États-Unis
unis et de leur salaire dont le travail est
le ralentissement économique des leurs
leurs pays
enfin quand l'union européenne et met
sa monnaie est l'euro basé sur
Marque allemande donnant un extraordinaire
puissance économique ou à l'Allemagne
piège s'enclenche l'euro se révèle immédiatement
pays défavorables de l'économie plus
faibles qui ne suivent pas
Le rythme allemand reste dans l'union
ces pays ont besoin de beaucoup
argent prévoyant cette situation
les états-unis créent un institut
financière privée la banque dont
la filiale en europe est basée en allemagne
[Musique]
la banque accorde alors un prêt au
gouvernements qui l'exigent
mais il impose des intérêts exagérés
impossible d'honorer
c'est une dette qui n'est jamais payée avec le
passer des décennies sur les intérêts
ces dettes augmentent incommensurablement
alors que l'europe digère encore un
ces nations arriérées de l'est qu'il a
avalé en plusieurs bouchées
les dirigeants des pays qui doivent à la
des banques comme l'Italie et la Grèce le font
se plaindre d'intérêts usuraires qui
leurs prédécesseurs ont accepté
ils menacent aussi de ne pas les honorer
la banque n'attend plus rien pour mettre en place
le plan américain se renverse avant
tous les gouvernements d'Italie et de
la grèce avec des coups d'état sans précédent
Les démocrates les remplacent par des dieux
cadres non élus soumis à sa propre
ordres
[Musique]
puis il impose son jeu
imitation des caisses de santé
public et pour l'éducation à la diffusion
de la désinformation anti-valeur de même
la justice est entravée deux siècles de
luttes syndicales et droits acquis
ils sont violés ils sont seulement conclus
les manœuvres spéculatives en faveur de
banque comme la vente d'actifs de
territoires nationaux et les meilleurs
entreprises
peur de perdre son emploi e
ne pas en trouver un autre devient
permanent
la banque ne s'arrête pas et menace aussi
Espagne, Portugal, Irlande et
France
poursuivre leur effondrement économique
afin qu'ils restent subordonnés à
états-unis et allemagne
[Musique]
désespéré pour le capital je
Les pays européens décident alors de
se débarrasser de leurs vieilles armes
cette ressource devient obsolète alors que
la demande d'armes reste forte dans le
continents des pays sous-développés
[Musique]
donc je les vends quand ceux-ci
les pays reçoivent des armes se déchaînent
[ __ ] ils massacrent tellement
férocement que leur peuple fuit
l'europe perdue désespérée face au
mort sur des bateaux délabrés
les plus chanceux arrivent désorientés
détruit par le voyage et la douleur
ils parlent une autre langue et espèrent que non
refoulés se comptent par centaines
de milliers tous nus et affamés et les
leurs sanctions résultent de la vente de
ces maudites armes
l'union européenne subit ce nouveau
souffler un peu en se sentant responsable
envers ces malheureux qui réclament le
droit à la vie
ils se proposent de les loger et de les nourrir
comme des frères d'autres disent qu'il faut
Jetez-les par-dessus bord parce qu'ils sont de
une autre race et une autre religion
d'autres encore plus modérés disent que oui
besoin de ces bras pour moi
des jobs que personne ne veut plus faire
Les pays européens partagent ensuite ces
les pauvres malheureux leur donnent un
logement misérable et le nécessaire pour
se nourrir puis les faire travailler plus
dur
[Musique]
alors face à tant de générosité
l'europe revient au bon temps des esclaves
à la différence que s'ils étaient avant
capturé de force maintenant
les esclaves arrivent seuls est inévitable
pour un caprice du destin et pour
l'ambition d'une histoire humaine
de l'europe a été fondé sur les armes et
sur les esclaves
le drame de cet exode reste souvent
inutile des fugitifs aux guerres qui oui
ajouter aux mendiants européens du
travail créé par la banque pour sortir de
cette confusion aux peuples de l'union
il ne reste qu'un seul mouvement
démocratiques organisent tous ensemble une
référendum et demander à leurs citoyens
si je suis d'accord ou non avec le syndicat
Européen avec l'euro imposé sans
les consulter et avec des gouvernements non élus
si 500 millions d'Européens ne sont pas
d'accord et les pays de l'union
reprendre leur souveraineté comme quand
ils étaient riches et puissants et qu'un mandat
d'arrestation internationale
si vous mettez contre les seigneurs de la
banque qui entraînent l'Europe vers le
misère
ça deviendra beaucoup plus fluide après tout